[Music]
did you know that
people are voluntarily putting tape
worms inside their bodies it's known
as the tapeworm diet it helps people
lose weight
by letting this parasite eat everything
inside of them
but this diet can go very
very wrong how would a tapeworm
affect your body well on today's
challenge
we're going to find out by having you
swallow a tapeworm
think you can handle it this is your
body on
tapeworms tapeworms
are flat segmented worms that can be
as long as 25 meters
they can't live freely on their own they
need to be in the gut of an animal or a
human to thrive
animals can become infected with these
parasites when grazing in pastures or
drinking contaminated water
how long do you think a tapeworm can
live inside your body
one week one month 20 years
we'll have your answer later in the
episode
there are two ways to get infected the
most
common tapeworm infection is called
teniasis
you get this if you eat undercooked meat
or
fish from an infected animal the
tapeworm
larvae in the animal muscle tissue would
migrate to your gut
you can also get infected if you're in
contact with
animal feces or contaminated water
from an animal with tapeworms this type
of infection
is known as cysticercosis you get this
by ingesting
microscopic tapeworm eggs it's
rare to get a parasite this way but it
can happen
in countries with poor sanitary
conditions
in both scenarios you wouldn't feel a
thing
if you have a cystic surcosis infection
the eggs you ingested
will hatch into mobile larvae once
they've entered your intestines
they could migrate out of your
intestines and
infect organs other than the digestive
system
but throughout your first week it's
likely you won't notice
anything at all let's see what happens
when we keep going
let's go back to the teniasis infection
[Music]
the tapeworm larva has developed into an
adult tapeworm in your intestines
and can be up to seven meters long it
attaches to the
inner wall of your intestines and feeds
off the food you're digesting
you could feel nauseous have abdominal
pain
diarrhea and you'd begin to lose weight
but it's also very likely that you
wouldn't feel anything at all
you may find out you have tapeworms by
taking a closer look at
what you've produced while sitting on
the toilet seat
at this stage pieces of the tapeworm
break off
and exit your body via your stool
and they look just like tiny worms
gross now that you've finally found out
you have tape worms
it's time to go to the doctor if you're
diagnosed with
teniasis your doctor will prescribe oral
medication
for one day it would paralyze the adult
tapeworm
which would let go of the intestine
dissolve
and exit your body via your stool
if the worms are large you could have
some
stomach cramping when they pass
okay you managed to escape a teniasis
infection but
what if you had cysticercosis instead
well if three months have passed and you
haven't noticed
this infection things would get terrible
a stomach cramp or sudden weight loss
would be
the last thing you're worried about
that's because the mobile larvae that
have migrated
throughout your entire body are mature
enough to form
cysts in tissues like your lungs brain
eyes or liver these cysts
could grow large enough to crowd the
functioning parts of the organ or reduce
its blood supply
you could have headaches or allergic
reactions
you might experience seizures in extreme
cases
to get rid of these worms you would need
surgery
or an organ transplant
and even after 20 years it's
still possible that the tapeworm could
live
inside of you without you even knowing
and your little buddy could measure more
than 25
meters long and if the tapeworm
continued to grow you would eventually
experience a digestive problem as it
blocks your appendix or
your pancreatic ducts so
tapeworms are horrible and creepy
and you don't want them anywhere near
you
regardless of the easy weight loss
[Music]
speaking of weight loss how about the
opposite
like gaining 300 pounds in a single year
well we'll see what that challenge
brings on another episode
of your body on